in his 2020 Memoir living in color
what's funny about me Tommy Davidson
writes that while filming the 1998
romantic comedy woo neither he nor Jada
pinket Smith were satisfied with the
script's ending he says he pitched the
idea of ending woo with the couple
dancing in the middle of a city street
and apparently everyone liked the idea
while dancing with his co-star in the
new scene Davidson kissed Smith without
warning though he said Smith flinched
when he kissed her at the time he quote
didn't think it was all that big of a
deal but there was someone who thought
it was a big deal Jada pinket Smith's
husband Will Smith according to Davidson
after the scene was shot Will Smith
followed Davidson into his trailer and
things got very heated between the two
Davidson explained there was a moment
there when we might have come to blows
my reactive fight or flight Instinct was
triggered and I could have exploded
thankfully Jada stepped in and helped to
calm things down and Davidson and will
remained good friends afterward